hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren wir schauen uns heute das
laserluca how it is WAP BAP ai Cover an
also ein Youtube Kanal hat mit Hilfe
einer künstlichen Intelligenz meine
Stimme so umgeformt als würde sie das
Lied WAP BAP von Bibi singen
genau das halte ich von dem Song
[Musik]
ihr müsst halt auch überlegen dass das
Video einfach nur 220 Aufrufe hat und
auch nur zwei Kommentare von denen ein
Kommentar einfach nur ein W ist und im
anderen Kommentar steht mach mal Bibis
Stimme mit ihrem eigenen Song als gar
keinen Sinn ergibt weil Bibi ja den Song
schon gesungen hat
man boyfriend
ich habe mich einfach beim Kacken
gefilmt damals das richtig
[Musik]
es ist ein starkes Musikvideo verstehen
aber es ist schon richtig krass was
mittlerweile mit einem möglich ist ne
oh mein Gott
da hatte ich einfach nie Scooter Unfall
deswegen war meine ganze Arme noch voll
mit Blut hallo
es ist so peinlich
[Musik]
scareds max
es ist so peinlich oh mein Gott
oh mein Gott ey was habe ich mich schon
alles bei was für Sachen gefilmt also
[Musik]
kurze Info bevor das Video zu Ende ist
ich habe nach 7 Monaten endlich mal
wieder ein neues Bild auf Instagram
hochgeladen und zu Feier des Tages
verlose ich unter allen Kommentaren in
50 € Amazon Gutschein also Laser Luca
heiße ich dort kommentiert mein neues
Bild und jetzt mal so einen schönen Tag
[Musik]